karl 150 canada 32 c'était il y a dix
ans pour la première fois de son
histoire l'onu disait non au canada
avant justin trudeau stephen harper et
son ministre des affaires étrangères
avait aussi échoué à obtenir un siège
mais il y a eu des moments plus glorieux
messieurs pierre st il propose à
l'assemblée générale la création de la
force internationale d'urgence des
nations unies en 1956 lester b pearson
n'est pas encore premier ministre quand
il défend cette idée ce que l'on devait
appeler par la suite les casques bleus
arrivent à partir des différents pays
c'est ce qui contribuera à mettre fin à
la crise du canal de suez et permettra à
l'artisan de cette nouvelle force de
plaies de devenir le premier et l'unique
canadien prix nobel de la paix pour le
canada favoriser la prospérité l'accès
aux opportunités est une valeur
fondamentale mais c'est essentiel on
essayait de la paix cela fait maintenant
deux décennies que le canada n'a plus
franchi la porte du conseil de sécurité
mais quel est le rôle de cette instance
les nations unies qui ont vu le jour à
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale ont
donné cinq sièges permanents au
vainqueur du conflit la chine les etats
unis la france le royaume uni et la
russie ont un droit de veto sur toutes
les décisions
ces décisions se prennent à 15 avec les
dix autres membres non permanents qui
sont élus pour deux ans
et en plus tu maintien de la paix le
conseil de sécurité vote des résolutions
pour la sécurité internationale des
recommandations comme lorsque le conseil
condamne les tirs de missiles de la
corée du nord des sanctions économiques
comme celles infligées à l'iran à cause
de son programme nucléaire mais aussi
des opérations militaires
internationales stationnées à près de
100 km des égyptiens des syriens des
saoudiens comme celle contre l'irak en
1991 contre et l'érable aux nations
unies le canada a déjà siégé six fois
dans cette instance
je suis encouragé par le fait que
d'autres pays
brian mulroney avait été associé à la
lutte contre l'apartheid dans les années
80 mais sans même avoir un siège au
conseil
justin trudeau peut donc garder espoir
d'y laisser sa marque ici mathieu prost
radio canada montréal